how did you become South savitur is a
version of Barry from the future he
remembers it everything that Barry does
when a fairy can't remember what we're
doing you oughta mess with his grave
just a little bit I want to stop you
from making your memory let's do it who
are you oh my officers to fight look how
the hell am I is this a dentist office
flash this Tuesday
hey everybody we're still freaking out
about that saboteur appeal so what's
going on with this episode as you can
see they follow up in the moments right
after last week's episode where Barry
and savat are Duke it out then he goes
back to team flash and they try to find
a way to stop Barry from getting new
memories so thats avatar won't learn
them and be able to use them against him
so there's so many questions that they
didn't answer last week that we need to
talk about like which version of Barry
is Savitt are in how are they going to
defeat him based on that because a lot
of you have already pointed out really
easy fixes like can he just kill himself
like Eddie killed himself but there's a
little bit of evidence based on some of
the things that the actors have said so
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so the title of the episode cause
and effect is then just using the
scientific method to try and find
different ways of stopping sabotage but
because we've already got the synopsis
for episode 22 in Barry at the end of
his rope trying to figure out a way to
stop savat are goes to Captain Cold for
help so that's a bit of a hat tip to all
the things that they try in this episode
to stops avatar aren't going to work
like nothing they try is going to change
him so there are a couple easy fixes
depending on which version of Barry's
avatar is so what we know as the show
has told us is that he is from the
future he says I am the future flash but
that doesn't necessarily mean that he's
from very far in the future because a
look at him he looks almost the exact
same age as Barry so if he is older he's
not that much older like remembered mo
Barry from 2024 he had the long hair he
almost looked the same age he was about
eight years older and because sabotage
has all the memories of what happened in
this moment here he knows exactly what
happened it means that he experienced an
identical timeline or he is this version
of Barry that we're seeing who's caught
in a time loop where he does all these
things to try and save iris but
eventually she dies he goes on to become
the 2024 emo flash in that a further
future date maybe a little while after
that something happens to cause him to
become sabotage but the big in the
armor is the philosopher's stone
because as Jay Garrick narrated it the
Philosopher's Stone was house avatar got
his power so there's a lot of different
characters telling us a lot of different
things that all seems to conflict with
each other so
almost like jay garrick doesn't have the
complete picture or somebody's being
dishonest or they're just narrating
things based on the telephone game where
they heard it from someone who heard it
from someone else and it's being lost in
translation so I will go so far as to
say based on what they're teasing like
all these left turns like oh you thought
you could stop sabotage you think you
can erase Barry's memories nope that's
probably not going to work either
that Barry trying to be selfless will
consider the option of killing himself
in order to stops avatar like the
scorched earth policy of stopping Sava
tar there'll be so much collateral
damage that it almost wouldn't be worth
it who knows what kind of darkest
timeline iris would see after that so
that probably will be considered but
won't be a fixed force avatars the
explanation I think for how he can be
this version of Barry but somehow not be
affected by any of the common ways that
you would fix something like that like
the eddy fix is the philosopher's stone
so as far as we know what does the
philosopher's stone do it has been
completely explained but so far we know
that it unlocks other versions of
yourself from different timelines not
from different earths because I know Joe
said earth 3 just as he was coming to
the conclusion about who's avatar was so
it just implies that this version of
Barry isn't from a different earth he's
from a different timeline in a somehow
found a way to use the Philosopher's
Stone to unlock his full potential his
full dark God speedster potential
because the reveal of Stav ATAR gets
back to that reverse flash line at the
beginning I have a feeling that the
twist behind who's avatar is and how he
was created how he's connected to Barry
all goes back to flashpoint so right now
the best theory before we get more
evidence is that sabot R is just a
different flashpoint version of Barry
that wasn't able to save iris didn't
have that love and went darkest timeline
then started jumping around looking for
ways to make himself more powerful and
bound the Philosopher's Stone and use
that to free himself from the timeline
where he gets trapped by Barry so it's
kind of complicated but the
philosopher's stone is still a very
important part of it the idea of the
flashpoint husk danielle Panabaker did
an interview earlier this season where
she talked about everybody having like
something dark inside of them trying to
get out that's probably what's avatar is
for Barry so killer frost is that dark
flash
pointing that's trying to climb out of
her and has done recently saboteur is
probably the version of that for Barry
but in order to achieve that
that's the philosopher's stone so
there's still a number of things that we
need to explain and especially how did
he get that scar over his eye so I
wouldn't be surprised if we see that
play out in some sort of flashback in
the future but I think you know because
of sort of like the downer reveal of Jay
Garrick and the time remnants in season
two they wanted to make the twist with
Salvatore and how he's connected to
Barry be a little more meaningful a
little more emotional and that's why
they spent all this episode talking
about how important love was and the big
arc with Joe and Cecile so it's almost
like they're weaving in some Daniel West
storyline to this to so if you don't
know who Daniel West is he's basically
like a version of the reverse-flash that
had this crappy upbringing and it's sort
of an example of what happened with the
zoom character during season two what
would happen if you grew up with a
terrible life and you got the powers of
the flash what kind of villain would you
become based on circumstance so it
sounds like the Sabbat our version of
Barry at some point just gave up on love
and said this is all terrible there's
too much pain I need to get rid of it
okay how can I do that I could become a
speedster God so he just goes down the
slippery slope and turns into the Darth
Vader character but the best metaphor
you could probably think of is that
saboteur is sort of like the culmination
of Barry's fear turning into a monster
itself there were some people that
thought this avatar might be a creation
of the Speed Force itself obviously
that's not true but it's sort of like
the Anakin Skywalker innermost fears of
someone manifesting physically in a
villain so every time around this year
they get to that part of the arc where
they're like okay the villain is to Opie
how do we defeat him if he's too
powerful for us
well if love is so important the easy
way one would be to find a way to bring
love back into his heart if that's even
possible into the bigger twist and what
I'm hoping they do is they say you can't
defeat him there's nothing you can do
about it you can't kill them you can
only hope to contain them but because
I'm expecting Barry to have to go into
the Speed Force I also wouldn't be
surprised if sabot R merges with Barry
and they go with more of a flashpoint
husk explainer where it's like two
versions of the same character because
look at him he does not look older than
Barry at all sohere's cannot wait to see
how much further in the
feature this version of areas from it
can't be that much further than 2020 for
Barry but let me know in the comments
what do you think the big twist is with
avatar how do you think they're going to
beat him and what's going to happen is
I'll try to post my arrow video tonight
but like there was a big dark tower
trailer there's a bunch of Marvel stuff
there was a Runaways trailer that posted
so tomorrow is Star Wars day it's May
the 4th may the 4th be with you so I'll
probably do a Star Wars video at least
but I'll try to do those are the trailer
videos as fast as possible where you
wait for that click here for the
defenders trailer again and click here
for that flash video thank you so much
for watching let's high five I'll see
you guys tonight